it's not just that it's work it's that
it's work that never ever ends because
your phone is in your pocket right so
you're sitting at home on a Sunday
morning having a cup of coffee and even
if you don't do it there's always the
possibility of oh I could tweet this out
to my followers right now I could turn
this into an Instagram story so the
possibility of converting even your most
private intimate moments into fodder for
your work life is always there now
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen Hughes Inga dr.
Nancy Bain is a communication scholar a
principal researcher in MSRs Cambridge
Massachusetts lab and something of a
cyber culture maven she spent nearly
three decades studying how people use
communication technologies in their
everyday relationships and written
several books on the subject
the big takeaway communication
technologies may have changed
drastically over the years but human
communication itself not so much today
dr. Bain shares her insights on a host
of topics ranging from the arduous
maintenance requirements of social media
to the dialectic tension between
connection and privacy to the fun house
mirror nature of emerging technologies
she also talks about her new book
playing to the crowd
musicians audiences and the intimate
work of connection which explores how
the internet transformed for better and
worse the relationship between artists
and their fans that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Nancy beim welcome to the podcast nice
to be here so you're a principal
researcher at the MSR lab in Cambridge
Massachusetts not to be confused with
the one in Cambridge England give our
listeners an overview of the work that
goes on in New England and of your work
in particular what are the big issues
you're looking at why is the work
important basically what gets you up in
the morning
so the lab in New England is one of
Microsoft's
smaller research labs we're very
interdisciplinary so we have people in
my basic area which is social media and
social issues around technology from
humanistic and social scientific
perspectives and we have that alongside
people working on machine learning and
artificial intelligence people working
on economics people working on
cryptography people working on math and
complexity theory people doing
algorithmic game theory and then we also
have a bioinformatics and medicine
component to this program also so we're
really interested in getting people from
very different perspectives together and
listening to each other and seeing what
kinds of new ideas get sparked when you
get people from radically different
disciplines together in the same
environment and you give them long
periods of time to get to know one
another and get exposed to the kinds of
work that they do so that's the lab as a
whole my group is we call ourselves the
social media collective which is a sort
of informal name for it it's not an
official title but it's sort of an
affectionate one there are three core
people here in our New England lab and
then which would be me Mary gray and
Tarleton Gillespie and then we have a
postdoc and we have in the summer PhD
interns we have a research assistant and
we're all interested in questions around
how people use technologies the kinds of
work that people do through technologies
the kinds of work that technologies
create for people and the ways that that
affects them their identities their
relationships their communities
societies as a whole you know as you
talk about the
types of researchers that you have there
I wonder is New England unique among the
labs at Microsoft I think we are in that
we are more interdisciplinary than many
of them I mean our Redmond Lab obviously
has valuable from a huge range of
disciplines but it's also got a huge
number of people whereas we're a much
smaller group we're on one floor of a
building and there are you know anywhere
from 20 to 50 of us depending on how
many visitors are in the lab and what
the interns are around or whatnot but
that's still a really small fraction of
the redmond group so I think anybody in
a particular field finds themselves with
many fewer colleagues from their own
fields relative to their colleagues as a
whole in this lab whereas I think most
of our labs are dominated much more by
people from computer science right
obviously computer science is well
represented here but we have a number of
other fields as well so I think that for
grounding of interdisciplinarity is
unique to this lab that's great so the
social science research in the context
of social computing and social media
it's an interesting take on research in
general at Microsoft which is a
high-tech company how do you think the
work that you do informs the broader
work of Microsoft Research in Microsoft
in general I would like to think that
the kinds of work that I do and that my
colleagues are doing are helping the
company and technology companies in
general think in more sophisticated ways
about the ways that the technologies
that we create get taken up and get used
in with what consequences I think then
people who build technologies they
really want to help people do things and
they're focused on that mission and that
it can be difficult to think about what
are all the ways that that might get
taken up besides the way that I imagine
it were taking it up besides the purpose
I'm designing it for so in some sense I
think part of our group is here to say
here's some unexpected things you might
not be thinking about here's some
consequences or in the case of my own
work I'd like to think about the ways
that technologies are often pushing
people toward more connection and more
time with others and
more engagement and more sharing and
more openness and yet people have very
strong needs for privacy and for
distance and for boundaries and what
would it mean for example to think about
how we could design technologies that
helped people draw boundaries more
efficiently rather than technologies
that were pushing them toward openness
all the time
I love that and I'm in a circle back in
a bit
to some of those issues of designing for
dialectic and some of the issues around
unintended consequences but first I want
to talk about a couple books you wrote
before we talk about your newest book I
want to spend a little time talking
about another book he wrote called
personal connections in the digital age
and in it you challenge conventional
wisdom that tends to blame new
technologies for what we might call old
problems talk a little bit about
personal connections in the digital age
that book came out of a course that I
had been teaching for oh gosh 15 16 17
years something like that about
communication and the Internet and one
of the things that tends to come up is
just what you're talking about this idea
that people tend to receive new
technologies as though this is the first
time these things have ever been
disrupted so part of what that book
tries to do is to show how the way that
people think and talk about the Internet
has these very long histories and how
people think and talk about other
communication technologies that have
come before so for example when the
telephone was invented there was a lot
of concern that the telephone was going
to lead to social disengagement
particularly among women who would spend
all their time talking on the phone and
would stop voting which doesn't sound
all that different from some
contemporary ways that people talk about
phones only now it's the cell phones
that are gonna cause all that trouble
it's that but it's also questions around
things like how do we present ourselves
online how do we come to understand who
other people are online how does
language change when it's used online
how do we build relationships with other
people how do we maintain relationships
with people who we may have met offline
and also how do communities
and social networks form and get
maintained through these communication
technologies so it's a really broad
sweep I think of that book is sort of
the one-stop shop for everything you
need to know about personal connections
in the digital age if you just want to
dive in and have a nice little compact
introduction to the topic right there
are other researchers looking into these
kinds of things as well and is your work
sort of dovetailing with those findings
in that area of personal relationships
online yeah yeah there's quite a bit of
work in that field and I would say that
for the most part the body of work which
I review pretty comprehensively in
personal connections in the digital age
tends to show this much more nuanced
balance for every good thing that
happens something bad happens and for
all of the sort of mythologies about
it's destroying children or you can't
trust people you meet online or people
aren't their real selves or even the
idea that there's something called real
life which is separate from what happens
on the internet the empirical evidence
from research tends to show that in fact
online interaction is really deeply
interwoven with all of our other forms
of communication I think you use the
word moral panic which happens when a
new technology hits the scene and we're
all convinced that it's going to ruin
kids today they won't have manners or
boundaries or privacy or self-control
and it's all technology's fault so
that's cool that you have a kind of
answer to that in that book let's talk
about your new book which is super
fascinating playing to the crowd
musicians audiences and the intimate
work of connection tell us how this book
came about and what was your motivation
for writing it so this book is the
result of many years of work but it came
to fruition because I had done some
early work about online fan community
particularly soap opera fans and how
they formed community in the early 1990s
and then at some point I got really
interested in what music fans were doing
online and so I
started a blog where I was posting about
music fans and other kinds of fans and
the kinds of audience activities that
people were doing online and how that
was sort of messing with relationships
between cultural producers and audiences
and that led to my being invited to
speak at music industry events and what
I was seeing there was a lot of people
with expertise saying things like the
problem is of course that people are not
buying music anymore so the solution to
this problem is to use social media to
connect with your audience because if
you can connect with them and you can
engage them then you can monetize them
hmm
and then I was seeing the musicians ask
questions and the kinds of questions
that they were asking seemed very out of
step with the kind of advice that they
were being given so they would be asking
questions like do I have to use all of
the sites how do I know which ones to
use so I got really interested in this
question of sort of what from the point
of view of these people who are being
told that their livelihood depends on
creating some kind of new social
relationship using these media with
audiences
what is this call to connect and engage
really about what does it feel like to
live with that what are the issues it
raises where did it come from and then
this turned into a much larger scope to
project thinking about musicians as a
very specific case but one with
tremendous resonance for the ways that
so many workers in a huge variety of
fields now including research feel
compelled to maintain some kind of
visible public persona that engages with
and courts an audience so that when our
next paper comes out or our next record
drops or our next film is released or
our next podcast comes out the audience
is already there and interested and
curious and ready for it well let me
interject with a question based on what
you said earlier how does that
necessarily translate into monetization
I can see translating into relationship
and you know followership but is there
any evidence to support that you know
magic Gretchen I thought so I knew it
you know I work with economists and I
keep saying guys let's look at this this
is such a great research problem is it
true right because you will certainly
hear from people who work at labels or
work in management who will say we see
that our artists who engage more do
better but in terms of any large scale
what works for which artists when and
does it really work across samples is
the million-dollar question that you
just asked is does it actually work and
I don't know that we know the answer to
that question for some individuals some
of the time yes for the masses reliably
we don't know well and the other thing
is being told that you need to have this
social media presence it's work you know
that's exactly the point of the book
yeah is it it's not just that it's work
it's that it's work that never ever ends
because your phone is in your pocket so
you're sitting at home on a Sunday
morning having a cup of coffee and even
if you don't do it there's always the
possibility of oh I could tweet this out
to my followers right now I could turn
this into an Instagram story so the
possibility of converting even your most
private intimate moments into fodder for
your work life is always there now and
the promise is oh if you get a presence
then magic will happen but first of all
it's a lot of work to even create the
presence and then to maintain it you
have to sell your personality now yeah
not just your stuff you have to be about
who you are now and make that identity
accessible and engaging and whatnot and
yet it's not totally clear that that's
in fact what audiences want or if it is
what audiences want which audiences and
for which kinds of products
[Music]
well let's get back to the book a little
bit in one chapter there's a subsection
called how music fans came to rule the
internet so Nancy how did music fans
come to rule the internet so the
argument that I make in that chapter is
that from the earliest earliest days of
the internet music fans and fans in
general we're not just using the
internet for their fandom but were
people who were also actively involved
in creating the internet and creating
social computing so I don't want to say
that music fans aren't the only people
who were doing this because they weren't
but from the very beginnings of online
interaction in like 1970 you already
have the very people who are inventing
the concept of a mailing list at the
same time saying hey we could use one of
these to exchange Grateful Dead tickets
because I have some extra ones and I
know there's some other people in this
building who might want them so you have
people at Stanford's artificial
intelligence laboratory in the very
beginning of the 1970s saying hey we
could use this enormous amount of
computing power that we've got to
digitize the Grateful Dead lyrics you
have community computing projects like
community memory being launched in the
Bay Area outputting their first terminal
in a record store as a means of bringing
together community and then from those
early early moments throughout you see
over and over and over again music fans
creating different forms of online
community that then end up driving the
way that the internet develops
peer-to-peer file-sharing being one
really clear example of a case where
music fans helped to develop a
technology to serve their needs and by
virtue of the success of that technology
ended up changing not just the internet
but industries that were organized
around distributing cultural materials
one of the reviewers of playing to the
crowd and these reviews tend to be
glowing right but he said it'll change
the way we think about music technology
and people so even if it didn't change
everything about the way we think about
music technology and people what kinds
of sort of aha findings might people
expect to find in the book I think one
of the big aha is the extent to which
music is a form of communication which
has become co-opted in so many ways by
commercial markets and alongside that
the ways in which personal relationships
and personal communication have also
become co-opted by commercial markets
think about the ways that communication
platforms monetize our everyday friendly
interaction through advertising and the
way that these parallel movements of
music and relational communication from
purely social activities to social
activities that are permeated by
commercial markets raises dialectic
tensions that people then have to deal
with as they're continually navigating
moving between people and events and
circumstances and moments in a world
that is so infused by technology and
where our relationships are infused by
technology so you've used the word
dialectic in the context of computer
interface design I've talked about the
importance of designing for dialectic
talk about what you mean by that and
what kinds of questions arise for a
developer or a designer with that
mindset so dialectic is one of the most
important theoretical concepts to me
when I think about people's
communication and people's relationships
in this project but in general it's a
concept that I come back to over and
over and over and the idea is that we
always have competing impulses that are
both valid and which we have to find
balance between so a very common
dialectic in interpersonal relationships
is the desire to on the one hand be
connected to others and on the other to
be autonomous from others so we had that
push and pull between I wanted us to
part of each other's lives all the
time and also leave me alone to make my
own decisions so that dialectic tension
is not that one is right and one is
wrong it's that that and as some of the
theorists I cite on this argue probably
infinite dialectic tensions between I
want this but I also want that in an
opposite right and so if we think about
social interaction instead of it being
some sort of linear model where we start
at point a with somebody and we move on
to B and then C and then D if we think
of it instead as even as we're moving
from A to B to C that's a tightrope but
at any given moment we can be toppling
into one side or the other if we're not
balancing them carefully so if we think
about a lot of the communication
technologies that are available to us
right now they are founded often quite
explicitly on a model of openness and
connection and sharing so those are
really really valuable positions but
they're also ends of dialectics that
have opposite ends that are also very
valid so all of these ways in which were
pushed to be more open more connected to
share more things they are actually
always in conflict within us with
desires to be protective of other people
or protective of ourselves to have some
distance from other people to have
autonomy and to be able to have
boundaries that separate us from others
as well as boundaries that connect us to
one another so yeah
my question for designers is how could
we design in ways that make it easier
for people to adjust those balances in a
way you could sort of think about it as
what if we made the tightrope you know
thicker so that were easier for people
to balance on and you didn't need to be
so good at it to make it work moment to
moment you know everything you just said
makes me think of you know say someone
who wants to get involved in
entertainment in some way and one of the
plums of that is being famous right and
then you find until they are until you
are that you don't have control over all
the attention you get and so that
dialect
because I want people to notice me I
want people to leave me alone becomes
wildly exacerbated there yes but I think
yes you know we all see over sharers as
my daughter calls them on social media
it's like keep looking at me all the
time it's like too much information have
some privacy yeah well you know but
that's a great case because I always say
too much information is not actually a
property of information or of the person
sending that information it's a property
of the person receiving that information
because in fact for some it's not going
to be too much information for some it's
going to be exactly the right amount of
information so I think of the example of
from my point of view a number of people
who are parents of young children post
much too much information on social
networks in particular I'm really really
turned off by hearing about the details
of their trivial illnesses that they're
going through at any given moment you
know I mean if they've got a real
illness of course I want to hear about
it but if you know they've got a fever
this week and they're just feeling a
little sick I don't really need daily
updates on their temperature for
instance on the other hand I look at
that and I say Oh too much information
but then I say I'm not the audience for
that hmm they've got 500 600 friends
they probably put that there for Grandma
and the cousins who actually really do
care and I'm just not the audience so
it's not that that's too much
information it's that that information
wasn't meant for me and instead of
blaming them for having posted it maybe
I should just look away and move on to
the next idea I feed that's okay too I'm
sure that some of the things that I
share strike some people as too much
information but then I'll tell you what
some of the things that I post that I
think of as too much information those
are often the ones that people will
later in other contexts say oh my gosh
it meant so much to me that you posted
about whatever so you know we just can't
make these judgments about the content
of what other people are producing
without understanding of the contexts in
which it's being received and by whom
that is such a great reminder to us to
have grace grace you've been watching
studying
writing about cyberculture for a long
time going back aways what did you see
or even foresee when you started doing
this research and what if anything has
surprised you along the way well it's a
funny thing I mean when I started doing
this research it was 1991 and the
landscape has changed so much since then
so that those kinds of things that I
could get away with being an insightful
scholar for saying in 1991 are
practically laughable now because people
just didn't understand at that time that
these technologies were actually going
to be really socially useful that people
were going to use these technologies to
present themselves to others to form
relationships to build communities that
they were going to change the way
audiences engaged that they were going
to change politics that they were going
to change so many practices of everyday
life and I think that those of us who
were involved in cyber culture early
whether it was as researchers or just
participants could see that what was
happening there was going to become
something bigger than it was in those
early days
[Music]
I ask all of the researchers that come
on the podcast some version of the
question is there anything that keeps
you up at night to some degree I think
your work addresses that you know what
ought we to be kept up at night about
and how are we to address it is there
anything that keeps you up at night or
anything that should keep us up at night
that we should be thinking about
critically as we're in this landscape
now
oh gosh does any of us sleep anymore at
all I mean I think what keeps me up
nights is thinking is it still okay to
study the personal and the ordinary when
it feels like we're in such
extraordinary tumultuous and frightening
times nationally and globally and I
guess what I keep coming back to when
I'm lying awake at 4:00 in the morning
saying oh maybe I just need to start
studying social movements and give up on
this whole interpersonal stuff and then
I say to myself wait a minute the reason
that we're having so much trouble right
now at its heart is that people are not
having grace in their relations with one
another - go back to your phrase that
what we really really need right now
more than anything is to be reconnected
to our capacity for human connection
with others and so in that sense then I
kind of put myself to sleep by saying
okay there's nothing more important than
actual human connection and respect for
one another and so that's what I'm
trying to foster in my work so I'm just
gonna call that my part and write a
check for some of us other causes I
can't contribute to you directly I I
love that answer
and that actually leads beautifully into
another question which is that your
social science work at MSR is unique at
industrial research labs and I would
call Microsoft still an industrial you
know situation definitely so you get to
study unique and challenging research
problems I have the best job in the
world no I do but you got a good one
because I talk to people like you but
what do you think compels a company like
Microsoft
perhaps somewhat uniquely to encourage
researchers like you to study and
publish the things you do what's in it
for them my lab director Jennifer J's
talks about it as being like a portfolio
which i think is a great way to think
about it so you have this cast of
researchers in your portfolio and each
of them is following their own path to
satisfying their curiosity and by having
some of those people in that portfolio
who really understand people who really
understand the way that technologies
play out in ordinary people's everyday
lives and lived experiences there may be
moments where that's exactly the stock
you need at that moment that's the one
that's inflating and that's the
expertise that you need so given that
we're such a huge company and that we
have so many researchers studying so
many topics and that computing is
completely infused with the social world
now I mean if we think about the fact
that we've shifted to so much cloud and
that clouds are inherently social in the
sense that it's not on your private
device you have to trust others to store
your data and so many things are now
shared that used to be individualized in
computing so if computing is infused
with the social then it just doesn't
even really make sense for a tech
company to not have researchers who
understand the social and who are
studying the social and who are on hand
with that kind of expertise as we close
Nancy what advice would you give to
aspiring researchers may be talking to
your 25 year old self who might be
interested in entering this field now
which is radically different from where
it was when you started looking at it
what would you say to people that might
be interested in this I would say
remember that there is well over a
hundred years of social theory out there
right now and the fact that we have new
communication technologies does not mean
that people have started from scratch in
their communication and that we need to
start from scratch in making sense of it
I think it's more important than ever
when we're thinking about new
communication technologies to understand
communication behavior and the way that
communication works because that has not
fundamentally transformed the media
through which we've used it has but the
way communication works to build
identity community relationships that
has not fundamentally magically become
something different the same kind of
interpersonal dynamics are still at play
in many of these things I think of the
internet and communication technologies
as being like funhouse mirrors where
some phenomena get made huge and others
get made small so there's a lot of
distortion that goes on but nothing
entirely new is reflected that never
existed before so it's really
unimportant to understand the precedents
for what you're seeing both in terms of
theory and similar phenomena that might
have occurred in earlier incarnations in
order to be able to really understand
what you're seeing in terms of both what
is new but also what's not new because
otherwise what I see a lot in young
scholarship is look at this amazing
thing people are doing in this platform
with this thingy and it is really
interesting but it also actually looks a
whole lot like what people were doing on
this other platform in 1992 which also
kind of looks a lot like what people
were doing with zena's in the 1920s and
if we want to make arguments about
what's new and what's changing because
of these things it's so important that
we understand what's not new and what
these things are not changing Nancy beam
it's been an absolute delight talking to
you today I'm so glad you took time to
talk to us
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Nancy Bane and
how social science scholars are helping
real people understand and navigate the
digital world visit microsoft.com slash
research
[Music]